I think they can see us a little bit I
don't think they can see us they're
thirsty for Augustus waters John is that
what it said yeah ha ha that's a funny
pun because these waters yeah it's an
important it's an important metaphor in
the book good morning Hank it's Tuesday
it's actually Monday we're on our way to
the Fault in Our Stars movie premiere
it's very exciting the collaboration
between the two of us and the community
that's emerged from it means more to me
than anything else in my professional
life and before we go do this crazy
thing I just want to say thank you
you're welcome
also thank you that's what I was waiting
for the mutual thank you
hold on I have to video blog really
quickly instead of a red carpet we have
a tip use blue carpet how awesome is
that
so I've assigned to some people who
lined up to produce the premiere and
then said hi to a lot more people who
had okay cloud posters by which time my
brain was slightly fried okay I have
successfully signed a bunch of posters
and everything not skin that's my rule
anything that's not skin and I am back
on the magic tip yes blue carpet so hey
currently across from me are like a
large wall of photographers that's what
hence all the flashes but I need to tell
you that the Fault in Our Stars movie is
coming out on Friday this Friday like
the day after the day after tomorrow on
us you go to the night before our stars
in which case it's coming out the day
after tomorrow if you want to see it on
Thursday at least in some cities that is
still possible you can go to the phone
Our Stars movie calm and get tickets
link in the doobly-doo I am sweating
through my Burberry shirt which is only
increasing my already sizable anxiety
then that will should afro Today Show
lab there are people from the Today Show
talking to me inside of my ear and then
getting the live chat with our
astonishingly beautiful and talented
hazel shading by the time that was over
things were starting to go quite crowded
I'm at Indy 500 winner Ryan hunter-reay
and things got even more crowded and I
kind of lost my ability to dinner I
don't know I don't know what to say I
don't have I don't have a I don't have a
talking part took a selfie with Mike
Birbiglia and then stood on the carpet
with my brilliant and lovely wife just a
few feet away from shaving and Laura
Dern and then I got to meet Spelling Bee
coach and being on some pseudo
unquestionably the highlight of my
evening ok Hank I just did all of those
press interviews and now I'm going to go
into the movie look look look look look
look that's the movie well like they
didn't let me film inside the theater so
greetings from Tuesday where my view of
Manhattan is not half bad thank the
premiere was just absolutely amazing
laughing and crying with 1200 people and
I'm so glad that you were sitting there
two seats away from me so I before is
anything else I just want to establish
that I'm not getting paid for the movie
like I got paid for the rights a long
time ago but I don't get a percentage of
ticket sales or anything and I don't
have to talk about it and if I didn't
like it believe me you'd know but in
fact I love the movie I think it's
amazingly faithful to the book and
powerful and funny and move
thank the people who made this movie
cared about the story and they care
about each other and you can really see
that last night we all got to be
together one last time which was sad in
a way but it was also very exciting
because it means that soon in fact very
soon everyone will get to see the movie
thanks to all of their invite Tara for
being part of this process with me read
the book first and Hank I will see you
on Friday when the Fault in Our Stars
movie will be out in theaters everywhere
I'm doing Hank well so what kind of you
know great premiere that we have but you
know okay Hank